I said before it helps to visualize
right and see what's going on so that
you can try and predict what you're
going to get at the other end and then
prove it algebraically okay so you have
P moving around some place such that the
angle you get from a to that point to
the solid point to B will be 90 degrees
okay
now I can draw a couple of these very
easily because it's a you know I've got
a perpendicular coordinate axes right so
for example the easiest spot where I can
put this is that's where PE can be
that's a right angle and I could put one
on the other side that would work just
fine okay but there are other spots
there are other spots for instance
another running well then I could do
another right angle maybe you say that
okay I could maybe go here and I think
I'm pretty much gonna stop there right
what does this thing look like my friend
is a semicircle for me right because the
angle in a let's put in there the angle
in a semicircle is always 90 degrees
that's actually the exact wording of one
of the circle properties that you
learned right so what I'm tracing out on
this side is a semicircle I can have
that 90 degree angle happening on the
other side as well so I'm expecting a
circle of some description right by the
way what circle is it a B is important
to this circle what is a B to the center
it's the diameter right okay good so
I've got a couple of POD lay out in
front of me I could say right that's a
diameter in the center of this circle or
to be in the middle the midpoint of that
diameter right once I have the center of
the circle what else do I need to define
a circle I need the radius right I can
find the coordinates here by doing the
point a B right and then I can find the
radius by going from
or to a if you like that'll give me the
radius okay that's fine
that's correct there's a more direct way
then Oh have a look right maybe it was
90 degrees right so let's take on let's
take this example on page right now what
you can see is that a P and P B right
they are perpendicular but that's what
means to have this 90 degrees right hey
B but that means something think who
wanted geometry reported military that
means something about the gradients of
these two intervals
does it hurt yeah when lines are when
intervals are perpendicular their
gradients should multiply to give
negative one okay see that see that line
I just wrote down color okay this line
here is my entry point just like this
line is an entry point and this right is
an entry point right once you know the
geometric feature you're going after the
rest is not it wrong what is the
gradient from a or AP it's rise over one
is it is well okay I mean for that
particular one into it but it could be
anywhere I just beat that one example if
this is a and this is P I take the
gradient to be y plus seven right is
right and wrong will be X plus two right
okay there's the gradient of a pain
what's the gradient of P be it's gonna
be y -1 y -1 or very good and that's
negative one okay we've been doing some
quadratics recently you see him there
you seen there okay let's have a look
what am I gonna get here I want a pair
of numbers that's it's going to I'm
gonna add them to get
squared plus 6y and then I'm going to
multiply them to get minus seven
yeah that's just my extension this is
negative one I'm just leaving about the
front for a second what's going to come
over when I cross multiply x squared he
adds to that and he multiplies to that
happy so what am I done
I've got these guys on the top and they
become this I've got these guys on the
bottom and I just put them over the
other side now cuz they're negative I
can just add them all over here right
there's the atom all over so I've got y
squared plus 6y minus seven plus this
whole thing cuz I got a minus sign
outside the whole piece okay
now remember what you're anticipating
right does it look like what you're
expecting these are the right pieces
okay I just need to 1 complete the
square a couple of times yeah so if I
take the negative seven in the negative
eight kick them over the other side they
become 15 you came back what do I have
to add to this to complete the square I
have which gives me 3 and I square which
gives me 9 very good there's one piece
what do I have to add to this to
complete the square one you added nine
and then you added one that's an adding
10 ok and now I've got my perfect
squares right y plus three X minus one
what's this guy that's 5 squared isn't
it okay so have my set up and I have my
radius which of course you could have
found by doing midpoint and then by
doing the distance formula but this way
directly gets at this property that they
gave to us right which by the way is
just another way of proving that be
anyone a semicircle is 90 degrees
because I never invoked that did you
notice I didn't need to say that's true
I've proven that it's true I've got a
circle at the other end